welcome everyone to the technology track
so this is a lightning round we have
seven sessions three minutes each and
we'll keep the time the idea is to
stimulate discussion around common
themes but get a lot of ideas in play
hence the seven but to have time for
discussion
hence the three minutes per session per
talk so we'll have the seven sessions
then at the end of it what I'll ask
people to do is to think of questions
that have come up for you what common
themes you saw what questions came up
and discuss with one or two neighbors
for two minutes to think through what
questions you'd like to ask and then
I'll call for questions so our first
speaker
so hi I'm Daniel Lee and I would like
today I would like to introduce our
recent work in our group specifically
linking more content using human
language technology and by linking I
mean how to associate relevant topics
well rather than piece of contents from
different places like different MOOCs or
different forms of course materials so
if a student they are interesting like
in in topic 2
so by assessing those linkings they can
find maybe grab a piece of content in
videos or in discussion or in text book
etc and they can maybe also find rebbe
reb and like preliminary topics or
advanced topics so in this way we would
like to make student enable student to
create their own learning paths and we
hope to make the one-size-fit-all
current teaching technologies to more
customized one so today I would like to
introduce several small topics with
aspects we export so the first question
we asked is if we can really establish
those kinds of linking does this really
help in learning so we come down to one
user studies on exporting to content
delivery strategies with a manual
linking one I mean we established
linking with experts and to link
course materials together and with
unlinking interface all those course
materials are presented separately and
we test several learning applications a
search and a summary applications and we
are evaluate when we found with our
linkings interfaces student can search
faster and connect and summarize better
so Lincoln seems help however to
establish linking manually it's not a
scalable solution so we also propose a
crowd sourcing strategies to ask online
workers to do those annotations for us
and we compare the result to expert
annotation data and those annotation
data can be used to establish the
linking system and can be used to train
a linking system and evaluating system
and we found the quality of a linking
based on the
unlike workers can achieve similar
quality to experts and the third one is
we also propose a graphical model based
linking algorithms which can use human
language technology to predict linking
automatically and we also compare this
algorithm to a more conventional
information retrieval method cosine
similarity and we evaluate our results
on crowdsourcing established annotation
data and we found our graphical model
based messer can significantly improve
the linking prediction accuracy so the
take-home message is the linking system
seems help at least in certain aspects
of learning applications and the h.o.t
and crowdsourcing technology is
promising for us to establish a
automatic and scalable system yeah
thanks if you look at face-to-face
education we all understand and realize
that the best face-to-face education can
be really valuable it can help us both
socially and well as well as
intellectually and creating that kind of
value online is something that we all
really want to do but when doing so I
think it's important that we try not
simply to replicate what works in the
offline world in the online context I
think what we should do instead is to
look at online education as an
opportunity to go beyond being there so
today what I would like to talk to you
about is how do we create educational
experiences online that are simply
unavailable as where for instance one of
the great assets of the online world is
the student diversity that we see in
those classes to leverage that diversity
we put this online small group
discussion to call talk about and you
can see a screenshot here it's been used
by around 3,500 students in ten massive
classes both on open EDX and Coursera
the way it works is that instructors
create a discussion agenda that you can
see on the left
and then when students log in and to
talk about talk about automatically
groups them into a small group
discussion with classmates from around
the world and because he grouping from
classmates around the world you can
create a unique discussion experience
that you don't see elsewhere so this is
a discussion from the social psychology
class and talk about grouped this
student from Texas with someone in Saudi
Arabia and as can see from his quote
it gives him the space where he can talk
about the topic but someone he would
have never met otherwise
so this underscores something which I
think is really important when you have
all the world to choose from you can now
algorithmically form groups say based on
you know student performance or if you
want to have groups which had balance
and gender or have greater geographic
diversity and you've seen that if how
you choose these groups matters so we
ran a randomized controlled experiment
and the social psychology class and we
assign students to groups either from
with parts one's from the same country
or discussion groups it parts ones from
many countries and we find that in the
final a week later if you're assigned to
a group with parts with so many
countries you tend to do better and this
is significant both in this class as
well as in applications in other classes
one reason for this is of course you
become more of an active thinker if you
see people who are different from you
so my dissertation research again is
about creating these online experiences
which are different and unavailable as
we're talk about is one of the two
systems in my dissertation the other is
just this tool called peer studio for
near real-time feedback on open-ended
work like essays you can find out more
about both these projects as well as
papers links to open source code and
resources at this URL and I would love
to talk with anyone who's interested in
leveraging these opportunities thank you
third speaker hello everyone I'm sange
it's Asia I'm a professor at UC Berkeley
and at Berkeley over the last year or so
we've been working to enhance learning
in lab based MOOCs by lab based MOOCs I
mean these are MOOCs for on-campus
courses that have a physical lab
component an example of a course like
this is introduction to embedded systems
a course that I teach at Berkeley which
has a lab in the first six weeks where
the students learn to program a mobile
robot the iRobot create in this case
that's interface to controller board and
as you see it has to avoid obstacles
climb this ramp not fall off and reach
the flat portion the so-called hill and
here the students get a real hands-on
experience but it's not just the
hands-on experience here it's also the
access to TA is the excellent ease we
have like the one on the garba through
these pictures on the side and it's
really that combination of hands-on
experience bus plus feedback from TAS
that makes this a great learning
experience for them so our goal is how
do you build an online virtual lab with
the learning experience that's
comparable to this one so simulation is
the only solution that currently scales
to the to the MOOC setting and so we
built a custom virtual lab environment
called cyber sim but importantly
connected that to an automatic grading
system called CPS grader both designed
at Berkeley and as you see here in CPS
grader if the student wants to debug
their solution they run a battery of
tests and they can run it in debug mode
and then when it runs right there the
this the this tool not only tells the
student if their solution is right or
wrong but gives them personalized
feedback about mistakes that they may
have made even though a particular test
may have passed right so that the
they can't get a kind of feedback that
an instructor or TA would give them in
the lab and this technology is based on
work in an area known as formal methods
we specify the goals or the faults in
notation called signal temporal logic
and we automatically synthesize these
temporal logic testers as running in the
backend so as I mentioned we we ran this
in a MOOC version of the class on EDX a
few months ago and here are some key
statistics 86% of the students found the
auto grader feedback useful we had an
optional hardware track where some
students purchased Hardware a very small
fraction of students purchased hardware
and over 90% of them said that if the
solution worked in the virtual lab then
past the auto grader it also worked for
real and then students spent about 5
Elena was a week and the peak enrollment
the the passing rate excuse me was four
percent of the peak enrollment I think
this area of lab based MOOCs is a really
exciting one both from the research
perspective and the teaching perspective
there's lots of future directions to
really enable virtual labs in the range
of science and engineering topics and
I'm looking forward to building
collaborations so that if you have a
course that you want to a lab based
course you want to take outline and you
can build a simulator connected to CPS
grader and we can build a nice lab
experience for your course and so
there's many exciting areas to combine
formal methods or other topics and this
tool will be open source later this year
thank you our fourth speaker
good morning everyone
I recently worked on a project I'm Saban
II from India currently an undergraduate
final year student we were gonna project
on blended MOOCs which was an initiative
by IIT Bombay India has a large number
of students interested in information
and technology and there are many
institutions in India are providing this
education there are around 5000 colleges
in India but the concern is the quality
of education we require and IITs in
India are the most prominent Institute's
they provide a high quality education
there there are about 1.5 million
students appearing for the entrance
exams to these institutions every year
but the intake is around ten thousand so
that is a problem and hence IIT Bombay
has created a solution to provide good
quality education their own lectures to
all the institutions in India why are
they doing this because by providing
lectures the time spent by the faculty
with these students will significantly
increase the time they're either spent
lecturing they'll spend on quality
discussions the practical sessions will
be held under the supervision of the
faculty in the local institutions this
will help the students learn better and
the essay type answers or the ODA
questions like we encountered in EDX
will be assessed by the faculty rather
than the AI grading so we worked on two
aspects one was the open response
assessments and we worked on multi stage
large assignments the open response
assessments these self that was the same
one self grading then the peer in case
of assignments involving groups we had
two kinds of peer evaluations intergroup
and intra-group so in
group the groups would evaluate each
other and an intra group the members of
the group would evaluate each other and
there would be the staff grading since
the AI and the machine learning
techniques are still under development
for better accuracy and the multistage
large assignments we have a concept in
India of submitting a final project a
mini project at the end of a course so
there there are generally three steps
involved one is the group formation this
will be done either by the teacher or by
the student then there is the assignment
approval the student submits his or her
idea of the project and it is approved
or rejected with the reason and the
assessment will be carried out in the
same order fashion self peer or staff
thank you our first speaker
hi I'm John tot wiki from MathWorks
if you're not familiar with math works
we're a company here in the Boston area
that develops mathematical modeling
simulation software our two core
products or MATLAB and Simulink and were
used in a wide variety of applications
from general programming data analysis
visualization modeling simulation and
general scientific computing starting
around the end of 2012 we started to
have a lot of professor's approaching us
who had used our tools as part of their
research and as part of their
residential courses and wanted to carry
these tools over to the MOOC and what
I'd like to share with you today are
sort of the three ingredients to the
success that we found in supporting
these efforts and these stem based
courses that we're using the tools so
the first is access and this could be as
simple as providing a download to
students however a much richer
experience is to integrate directly into
the MOOC provider platform and this
opens up all sorts of new opportunities
for instructors including replacing
hardware based labs with software
simulations and using the MATLAB
language to perform automatic assessment
of student submissions now in addition
to providing access to the tools there
also needs to be content to help
students learn how to use these tools
and apply them to the concepts that are
being discussed in the course and so
this is something where we've been
active in providing content for
instructors as well our design
philosophy here has been just-in-time
just enough and so what we're doing is
providing very targeted modules that can
be inserted in with the assignments so
that students are able to get exactly
what they need at the time that they're
doing the assignment and if you think
about sort of the the stress that a
student encounters they're already
overwhelmed with having to learn
everything in the course let alone a new
software tool on top
of that as well as the stress of
instructors who have to create all of
this content this is something that
hopes to save a lot of time in that area
the final tier here is support and so we
don't just provide these materials and
walk away we actively monitor and
respond to the discussion board to help
students and this has the interesting
side effect is we get feedback as well
as to how students use our tools to
learn and what we could do to to improve
so to summarize the access learning and
support the three tiers here for
providing excellent tools for
instructors to teach and for students to
have a hands-on learning experience
thank you our six speakers
hi my name is Jake Hirsch Alan I'm run a
software development company in Toronto
called functional imperative and a
software boot camp in Vancouver called
lighthouse labs but I'm actually here in
my capacity as a representative for the
United Nations Special Envoy for
education currently Gordon Brown former
UK prime minister and he's got a
proposal called the global education
platform which is an attempt to bring
together a number of thus more
influential groups in online education
and using technology to in essence build
a platform that will help those most in
need which is to say those with least
access to those online tools the goals
are pretty ambitious and so in about
three minutes I'm just gonna probably
hit those goals and I'd be happy in the
discussion period to get into some of
the actual projects and platforms that
we're looking at building that it's been
about a year now that we've been working
on this we've had a meeting in December
with a number of the key players
involved Brookings is running the
content and accreditation committee in
conjunction with the OECD I'm working
with a number of software companies from
Mozilla to EDX to international
organizations like the UN Global Compact
to really bring together the key players
and the idea at the highest level is
that the current global education system
can't supply the quantity or quality of
education necessary to meet
international demands and that's
particularly true at the bottom of the
pyramid and the technology sort of
provides in some ways that means to do
so this was in essence the promise of
MOOCs unfortunately as most of you
probably know MOOCs are barely achieving
that promise in the developed world let
alone the developing world and so we're
really looking at building a platform
that'll fix a number of the problems
that exist with the current online
education tools or at least try to do so
so some of our goals include aggregating
educational content from a diverse range
of providers establishing standards for
quality of content type of content
technology we have to ensure that all
this content is localizable obviously
not easy and most importantly that it's
accessible so it's gonna probably have
to come in some form that is both
including video and images text and even
SMS we want to ensure that there's some
sort of accreditation component one of
the key factors for most of these
individuals is that once they achieve
this education they need to be able
to then apply it in a way that can sort
of get them a job I wanted to quickly
touch on a couple of the partners before
I get to the end of my time I'm gonna
jump through slides on MOOCs which you
all know much about and go through the
list of some of the people who are
working with us because you can see that
each of these organizations can play a
role in ensuring that for instance the
education we're working on focuses on
primary education that is to say K
through 12 rather than the usual MOOC
platforms which obviously are these days
mostly focused on post-secondary free to
end users that in some ways it's going
to have to be a pick-your-own adventure
type platform because the levels that
people are gonna be interacting with it
are gonna range dramatically it's
hopefully going to include things like
the best of some of the pedagogical
learnings that have been discussed today
and yesterday from flipped classrooms to
hybrid classrooms and finally it's going
to be supported by governments companies
and educators and employers around the
world thanks and our seven speaker
actually has two bodies and two heads
hi I'm Jeff Helmer from the University
of Texas at Austin I teach music they're
my collaborators Andrew Smith Lewis he's
the founder and executive chairman of
Sarah go Sarah goes a memory management
company that helps students learn faster
and remember longer in a variety of
topics and in January of 2014 on EDX we
collaborated on a course that was very
successful in jazz appreciation so what
we've done is designed a content to try
to bring together the massive numbers of
people were able to reach with MOOCs
with the personalized learning
experience that's involved in Sarah go
so are we use this for most of our
assessment for this course and we're
using it in our continued ut-austin
courses as well as a primary means of
assessment so what we're able to do is
we've been able to create content that
Andrew will soon be demonstrating here
that teaches many of the facts that are
discussed in the jazz course and also
helps in BA and B musical concepts into
the students and allows for the
collaboration to be individual and for
the teaching to be individual in that
way so I'm going to turn it over to
Andrew now to talk a little bit more
about what's going on thank you Jeff
so what's going a little jazz this
morning nothing like two minutes in a
live demo so I'm on the EDX platform
right now I'm looking at two courses
that have been integrated with the art
platform biology here and also jazz I'm
gonna show you our jazz course and in
the jazz course here we've got a
practice your knowledge section built in
through LTI into the EDX platform and
there are several modules here how jazz
works jazz facts deeps listening I'm
gonna run our jazz facts too and the
idea here is that the application what
it does is take foundation and space it
out over time so people can really
master the basics all the content was
created by Jeff so here we've got my
memory bank that shows my progress on
content I can see when I last studied
the content or what my upcoming schedule
of review is all managed by the system
I'll show you what a little content
looks like when I run it it comes up and
it says hey do you remember which
artists recorded a Love Supreme
any takers we're gonna go with Johnny
Coltrane
so there's
item in the system we've got some notes
there that will give me some background
about a coal train I can listen to a
little bit of jazz I'll contribute
move on to the next item can a man error
from the artist my fusion error I will
get this incorrect and I'll repeat that
item and in the background what the
system is doing is looking at not only
when I'm given a question do I get that
question correct or incorrect but how
difficult was the task and it uses all
that information to figure out when I
should see that content again in the
future if I jump back to the I'll show
you what goes on for the instructor as
well on the analytic side so here I'm
looking at a course that Jeff is
actually running live right now and all
of these little heads are individual
students so Jeff can zoom in and see how
his students are doing this is a live
class at UT Austin I can see when they
last studied or what their upcoming
schedule of review is I can zoom in on
an individual student and see what items
they're struggling with what content is
easier what content is difficult for
them so now I've run out of time we have
a lot more to show you and we hope to
get a chance to meet with you all in the
future thank you okay thanks to all our
speakers so you should have some ideas
for what themes came up for you what do
you wonder about what questions you have
so spend now just one to two minutes
actually with a neighbor or two
discussing that what questions would you
like to ask the speakers so this is one
way to give the introverts also a chance
to ask questions so it's not just
extroverts session only
okay so
okay what questions do you have for our
panel
what spark your interest made you wonder
microphone should be coming over hi
Cassandra who are you from Caltech
several of you are integrating external
or new elements into existing platforms
so I'd love to hear more about the
process and the experience for students
in kind of crossing domains with those
apps or modules do you mean how was it
whether the students had trouble with it
or interested yeah more about the
student experience and whether it was
seamless or whether they have to jump in
so given I have two projects both of
which are external tools I thought I
would start actually students have an
easier time than you would imagine
because most of both the platforms that
have worked with open EDX and Coursera
have single sign-on mechanisms such as
open ID and the real the only thing that
students actually need to do is to click
a button and say login right but the
real challenge in using an external tool
or any tool for that matter with MOOCs
is making the value clear to students
right why should I be using talked about
or why should I be using my peer
assessment tool and if notice that just
by making that value clear we've got
from a point where 70% of students would
come to our external tools and do
nothing to a point where we've got
around I think today it was 73% of
students come in and decide to log into
the system so in removing the friction
is one part of it but the bigger part is
making a value clear to the students
just to answer that same question in our
case we had this virtual lab software
which it was was such that it couldn't
be integrated into the browser into the
standard EDX tools so we went for a
local grading solution a local solution
where students would download the
software run it locally on their
jeans and all the grading would actually
happen locally on the machines and then
it would the results would be
transmitted back to the edx server back
to our server at berkeley cross checked
and sent back to edx for the students to
see but all of this you know thanks to
some great work by people at EDX and
people at Berkeley was seamless from the
point of the students view where they
were submitting their code and then
almost instantaneously they would see
the results on EDX and the green
checkmark I think so we were very
successful in integrating with LTI with
EDX it was a pretty seamless process
there were no real problems we were able
to pass back data from our system to the
gradebook so that students right there
in the EDX platform could get a view of
how they're doing and the additional
analytics that Jeff was able to use and
we were able even to integrate it in
such a way that Jeff could determine
grades for students based on their
performance in the system the only thing
that we weren't very successful at our
first run was probably mobile so we have
a mobile solution as well and we only
saw about 10% usage on mobile so that's
something definitely we'll be working on
the next round to improve and for
mathworks it was actually an opportunity
to enhance the student experience for
the past thirty years or so we've been a
desktop application and if you've ever
started up or applications you know
they're complex engineering tools
there's a lot of features students get
overwhelmed seeing that for the first
time and so by integrating we were able
to pull out just the elements that were
necessary for the lesson and take some
of that away and make it a little bit
easier for the students the first time
around so I have a question for Texas
and Sara go i I'm sort of familiar with
the system it's a wonderful system the
way I understood that you track the
memory and ensure memory decay for each
learner in your MOOC so here's my
question were you able to identify
patterns among learners who are dropping
out as opposed to staying with the MOOC
okay
as you know attrition has asked me one
of the big issues I don't think we've
had that much research on that
particular topic but what we noticed was
we had a very good retention rate once
people started know what so we felt that
serega was one of the ways that was we
were able to keep people in the course
that kept them engaged more than the
traditional assessment on that so what
we saw at the end for everyone who
enrolled we saw that a twelve point four
percent completion rate based upon
performance in the Saragossa system and
sixty percent of those users scored on
the honor roll which was ninety percent
above and actually a third of those
users got a perfect score in the system
so we saw a good amount of engagement
retention how that transfers to
real-world knowledge is a separate
question you'll be interesting to see if
we can identify you know along with that
any any patterns among learners who
dropped out this is what we're all
trying to figure I agree
hi sorry just working the question is
the question is for the if that's led by
the special envoy the un special envoy
and we have different questions both
targeted at the same speaker and you
okay I just wanted to ask if all the
platform was meant to do is bridge the
employment gap or are you thinking of a
platform that will actually offer a wide
range of MOOCs to deliver two different
objectives that's a good question and
it's a challenging question because a
lot of the individuals in question need
primary education as I mentioned rather
than post-secondary education and it's
sort of hard to tie some very basic
climber education to some of the skills
that employers are looking for
particularly employers that for instance
are going to be participating in the
program I think in the end inevitably
we're gonna be focusing first on
education rather than on the employment
possibilities because a baseline is
going to be necessary and and that again
comes with the primary education focus a
teacher training focus but that because
both the incentives so financial and
otherwise and in some ways that drive or
the entire project has come from
companies participating in for instance
if you go the UN Global Compact
inevitably their interests will I think
steer the direction of that education
focus apply more education focus hi
Patrice fresco at Cornell University and
I wanted to follow up on the question of
the tools that are outside of the
platform you had said that students
download onto their own computer did you
have to provide tech support for
students like did they have issues and
were there any places in the world where
students couldn't download the software
so did you provide like an alternative
assignment for them so that's a great
question
yes we did have tech support for this
offering we partnered with National
Instruments
and the simulator that he saw the
robotic simulator is provided by ni so
ni as part of the participation had the
tech support team and this is a global
tech support so they had people in all
the major regions 24/7 able to answer
questions from students so that was that
was a great plus for us
of course the autograder the Oregon
grading system was completely developed
at Berkeley and students often if they
had issues that that and I couldn't
answer they were posted on the forum and
as anybody who would do a MOOC would
tell you right you need a team leaders
often a large and competent team and I
had a wonderful team of people both on
from my research group as well as from
ni and other people at Berkeley who were
looking at the forum and you know
anytime an issue came up they were very
great at responding to it so I think
that was a that was a big plus now in
terms of the download issue yes there
there were complaints about the size of
the download but it was a one-time thing
and we alerted the students well enough
in advance that I think everybody had
everything set up just fine and when the
time came for the labs to begin which
was two weeks into the course I think it
was pretty smooth sailing so talk about
is based on Google Hangouts and Google
Hangouts turns out it is blocked in
countries like Iran Belarus a number of
other places in the world and so yes
there are students out there who would
really like to use systems but can't
right now
I think the solutions that we have done
are there there isn't a single solution
but the ones if you've tried our aid
providing waves where they can have
alternative means of participation so
you can do an in-person discussion you
won't really get the benefits of a
global community but you have something
the other is to make the tools that we
have self-service as possible so if we
detect that Google Hangouts is blocked
in your country then we show you the
fact that it is blocked in your country
and/or you can't load it because you
don't have the
and we try and help students to go
through that and I think though I'm a
researcher I think I spend a lot of time
on student support in some sense I think
it's really important especially when
you're developing something new so
Whitby Australia for instance just
yesterday we had like 20 different
student inquiries as to how they should
use the system and we try and address
all of them to start with and then try
and convert them into self-service
tutorials for students to use I think
that model has worked pretty well you
know having this high touch to begin
with and then making it self-service as
we go thank you thank you for the
insight have you ever thought about
countries for example the country where
where I'm from where gender mixing is
prohibited anywhere anytime so in that
way learners will will lose the
opportunity to try the social activity
or the geographic diversified activities
well what was prohibited I'm sorry I
didn't hear gender mixing oh I see so
that's my Arabia correct right so the
example that I showed was a student from
Saudi Arabia and I think actually if you
think about it MOOCs are an opportunity
for students who are otherwise unable to
participate in education to do so right
so we've had lots of students for
instance my adviser teaches a class on
human-computer interaction and one of
the things that he told me was you know
people who have mobility problems right
can't go into the real world to do need
finding you can't just say go watch
people in line because it's hard to get
to some someplace that's public and if
you have a mobility problem and what we
can do with MOOCs is make it a little
bit easier for people who otherwise
don't have that access to get access to
such communication so I I don't really
know the social system in Saudi Arabia
but I know that a lot of students in
Saudi Arabia both men and women are
using talked about so yeah
yeah and I think in that case I think I
automatically my also help like a
automatic telogen to Turing's based on
some machine learning or natural
language understanding problem and I
think and yeah there are several ways to
solve that kind of problems or better
learning like you can learn by
discussion with your fellows you can
learn by automatic to your insistence
and I think yeah so I paid I think there
is a ways can solve by much learning or
more automatic way to do that well I
like that maybe add to your question I'm
not sure if it was answered is it that
it's for if for example gender mixing is
forbidden does that mean a MOOC course
to be offered in Saudi Arabia must
actually separate say sections or not
allow different genders to discuss on
the discussion forum would be needed
like you you should select the gender
you you will be or I mean honestly
speaking this should be controlled
rather than an option so as an issue a
new initiative with EDX as a Saudi
Arabia on a governmental level we have
this into consideration done
electronically or technology technically
to control the genders so basically okay
thanks so I've more of a comment than a
question but I run the biology courses
from MIT on EDX so I can vouch for math
works and Sarah go because we've worked
with them closely and I think the some
of the questions are about oh how listen
for students or how was it for users and
as a course team the thing that really
worked well was the support the math
work since ergo provided because
instantly if we had a bug or if didn't
really work exactly how we want it they
immediately responded and so if anyone's
thinking about using them they should
definitely you know I can vouch for the
positive experience on the course team
side
and on the student side there was a lot
of positive comments about both and I
think for Sarah go we're using it more
for our courses more for problem-solving
but it is flashcards a memory base but
the students and still need to know
basic facts and for biology and
vocabulary and I think that you know
just adding that as supplement to the
course helped a lot with the early on in
the course and the material to help them
just understand basic facts and help
with that part even though it didn't
count for a grade for them but they
enjoyed it there was a lot of positive
comments on the forum for it I want to
echo what you said about the great
support from Sarah go in our music
course we were able to not only cover
some of those facts but we were also
able to teach listening examples which
were really wonderful so we have the
students learn how to recognize
selections from a particular list and
also learn from unknown selections
musical aspects such as form rhythmic
feel a harmonic progression those kinds
of things and so we've been able to try
to find some other ways some other
topics to involve with Sarah go as well
and we found it seamless both in EDX and
in canvas which where we're using it now
and we're using it again as part of our
assessment for the grades for the course
do you think you could use it for for
example introductory calculus
integration techniques where you know
there's seven or so tricks for doing
integration variable substitution
treating substitution this in that
substitution where it could just see if
you get the right level of granularity
where the students need more practice
and less practice or how much
involvement would the faculty have to
have in doing the curriculum design to
do that I think math is a challenge for
our system it's not the best fit I can
tell you though anecdotally we just
finished this study in the k-12 space
with 4,000 charter school students over
a semester and algebra was one of our
best performing courses you got a 13
percent bump on a final exam against a
control group so you know they beat our
expectation and we certainly want to
inform the system to be better for math
but it is a tougher fit oh okay
interesting Thanks
so it seems also one theme that I hear
in many of the questions and answers is
the scaling problem in just tech support
how do you you know if something goes
wrong one out of a hundred times and you
have a hundred students well that's okay
but when you have a hundred thousand
students you're up all night all the
time answering questions on the forum
and how do you scale that so one thing I
think it would be good for everyone to
think about is how can you push the
knowledge back to the nodes of the
network so that people can either can
answer their own questions or find ways
that it doesn't all come into the center
so I completely agree with what you're
saying but I would like to say that
often we think of tech support is a cost
to deploying new technology and I think
actually it can be a great opportunity
after 20 emails that I told you about
yesterday I think all of them are in
some way me trying to do some neat
finding to see what students really need
to see how they're using the tool that
they use that we want them to use and to
see what is it that they're getting out
of the tool right so instead of simply
looking at it as a as a cost factor I
think it makes sense to also look at it
as a way of looking at how what students
need instead of just asking them in
surveys multiple times yeah so it's
anthropology and development at the same
time that's great I think to answer your
question how to scaling I think there
are several ways like in our cases we
use a tax information to do the
inference automatically and I think
there are several research like the G
Hakeem's and the flip goal they
announces millions of click logs with
the videos and to find the patterns how
to interact the videos have by which
part is more confusing or you can use
happy modeling to analyze the forints
discussions to find is there any similar
questions and you can answer those
questions once and you can make your
system more scalable also one I think
one also to add to that possibility is
context
based annotations so for example the
forums people say well I had a problem
on this problem or this issue didn't
work for me but you don't know it takes
you forever to figure out exactly where
people were complaining about or had
issues and if there was some way of
making comments right away as was
discussed say yesterday in the
annotation session that would actually
speed up the possibility of finding
where the problem is and maybe actually
for students to answer each other's
problems
question yeah this is more of a comment
and I'm Sejal from UT Austin part of
Jeff's team as well and a pleasure to
work with him just as a comment for tech
support and supporting these integration
tools and scaling them one thing that i
think sarah NGO and the team did really
well is also come up with an
introductory video for the students
right before the course so they know
what is the purpose of the tool how it
affects their learning and how they're
supposed to use the tool and we embedded
that in various parts of the courses as
well so that really helped ground the
students also and just let them be aware
of here are the browsers that are
supported you know this is how you're
supposed to use the tool this is where
you're supposed to use the tool and how
it affects your grade and learning so
that would that really help like
establish a baseline for the external
tool and also add in how they can get
support for the tool so that was a good
model that I think worked for our course
and that's consistent with the comment
your comment before that it really helps
one of the most important things is to
explain to students why are they using
this other thing communication is is
really key just getting that a couple of
weeks out early into the course we had
an embedded systems course as well and
that it had a software download and a
kit to buy but we allowed a couple of
weeks of time for that to get that all
flushed out thanks
yeah microphones coming embedded systems
course when you have kids involved in
lab kind of situations where they might
do virtual labs and kids how do you
scale that that's a great question we
had a lot of support from Texas
Instruments who helped to help the
course and sponsor the course as well so
they helped with a lot of the web-based
components delivering and signed the
kits globally and having distributors at
different countries so they were a big
partner in that course and just to add
to that in for our course as I mentioned
in my presentation we had an optional
hardware track the reason we made that
optional is we wanted the course to be
free but those students who could afford
something to pay for a kid had that
option and again the partnership with
the company providing the tools was key
in this case we we provided links to
students to buy the robot from i from
iRobot and to buy the the
microcontroller board from National
Instruments and thus - and we gave them
detailed instructions and how you put
them together and make the robot and
there was a small number of students who
are motivated enough to do that and and
so I think you know going forward I
don't I was I don't know if we make this
a mandatory option in the next iteration
of the course the option because you
know for students to take because it's I
think it's again there's lots of places
around the world where you can't it's
very hard to get access to the hardware
but we asked me did a survey at the end
and we our students in the course we
gave them four options like you know for
future offering would you be willing to
how much would you be willing to pay for
hardware okay and we asked them you know
the first option was I don't want to pay
anything it second was anything below
$100 is fine third one hundred to five
hundred and fourth I'm willing to
beyond 500 right and what was surprising
is a large majority I think I don't
remember the exact number but maybe 3/4
or 80% I think said that they'd be
willing to pay right and the large
majority of that was anything below $100
is fine so I think there's you know
these are all the students who were
engaged in the last week of the course
so that there is a population of
students out there who are willing to
pay and you know get the hardware and
try things out for these sorts of lab
based courses is but it's an access
question you know whether globally you
have that access yeah and to add to that
I mean we had a whole shopping cart and
TI handled the whole distribution for it
and we had about 11 thousand kits sold
through that through four different
countries so I mean there there is a
market there for students who are
interested in really trying this out
globally so that was good to know
okay since we have no more questions I'd
also like to invite the panel to say any
last thoughts that they have and
messages that you want to tell everyone
so two messages
I think lab based MOOCs are a super
opportunity not just for teaching but
for research in science and engineering
and I think so that's something that I
would really encourage the research
community to go out and think about
education as a new application domain
the second message is the particular sub
area of computer science that I work in
formal methods has a lot to offer to
education at large even beyond the
specific lab based MOOC work that we've
done I guess it's not so much a message
as an invitation right so I think we've
all taught people in some capacity or
another and I think I would like to
invite you to see what if you could have
this diversity that you see in the
online world or what if you had the
scale in your online world how could it
improve what you teach students instead
of trying to replicate what we have
already learned I think this is the
great opportunity here so if any of you
are excited about this I would love to
talk with you I think just take an
opportunity to summarize something that
I think is kind of the theme emerging
from here and that is when you
incorporate technology you know it's not
just providing that that access it's
really all the things that go along with
it you know providing that learning
content providing that support these are
things that you know aren't
insurmountable challenges but they are
things that need to be thought about and
you know there are a lot of good tools
out there something I was going to add
to the discussion is you know from our
experience just sort of monitoring the
discussion boards the community really
does kick in here and and great things
happen at that kind of scale where
students help each other we found that
when we do tech support on the
we often only need to respond to maybe
five or six items a week in a MOOC
because students are helping each other
so those are things to kind of keep in
mind when you're when you're thinking
about incorporating technology into your
MOOC so I think I just really briefly
wanted to suggest that I see the the
global education platform the GP as an
opportunity at this point for others to
participate in shaping how a lot of the
advances that you all are involved in
specifically will affect those who sort
of need it most and those who probably
haven't been talked about through most
of the sessions over the past couple
days and I think that the concrete ways
we do that as my presentation suggests
would remain quite open whether its
accreditation or whether it's an actual
technological device or a online
platform and I think that input from you
all is key in terms of making sort of
some decisions as to how the many
resources that hopefully will be
leveraged towards this platform are
directed and so I welcome that input and
we do as a platform I'm very bullish on
on MOOCs and I think that everybody in
this audience probably is as well and I
think we have to team up together and
show the world the value that can be
generated from these programs I think
that since I pointed out engagement and
retention are very key also transference
to real world results are very key and
we're really excited to donate our
platform to you all and our team of
instructional designers and learning
scientists to work with you to create
great showcases and to help educate
people on these platforms he has a
faculty member I just wanted to stress
up when I heard this morning and that's
the importance of having a team around
the faculty member and I'm very grateful
for the team that I have both from the
Center for teaching and learning at UT
Austin and from Sarah go and it's I
really appreciate many of you who are
serving on those teams who may not be in
the faculty spotlight I appreciate that
very much and the last thing I would say
is just that we think of a MOOC is a
large scale impersonal thing that's what
I thought about it as when I first
entered the project it was gonna and it
does reach many people but the personal
relationships that I've been able to
build with students in that move from
around the world have been one of the
most rewarding aspects of my involvement
in this kind of project
okay well hopefully you have some food
for thought about MOOCs and about
learning and how you may change your own
MOOCs or participate in MOOCs
differently or design them differently
let's thank our speakers for stimulating
those thoughts and discussion and now
let no one stand in the way of lunch